[Musique]
alors voila moi des fois j'utilise le
coefficient de bareilles
je regarde ça tous les jours ça varie
tous les jours dans mon métier des fois
ça marche bien et pourtant j'ai pas le
pied marin
je fais d'autres choses beaucoup plus
romantique par exemple des fois je vais
ramasser les bouses
rien n'est plus beau qu'une blouse
cueilli au culte de au cul de la vache
pardon avec pape l1 quand elle n'a pas
touché le sol très belle forme
ok vous êtes peut-être pas tout stopper
ça c'est pas joli ça pour changer le
temps ben ayed période de l'année où je
m'occupe des moutons car c'est sympa
parce que dans le fond bas on est bien
sûr ils se nourrissent perd on leur met
des petits plus et moi même de l'eau et
on leur changer la litière
c'est sympa forcément vous allez dire ce
cas qu'est ce qui fait en fait j'ai
peut-être médecin parce que je travaille
avec des plantes joli paquet compte
d'ailleurs vous avez vu ce beau
pissenlit là ça c'est un truc chouette
si vous savez pas quoi faire une fois
vous allez accueillir des pissenlits par
une belle matinée de printemps et il
faut les prendre quand ils sont à leur
première ouverture la physiologie pan
n'est pas mal le choeur est encore bien
serré qui sont tous retour en pin pon
chose un artisan huy tuân artisans assez
clair en fait un agriculteur oui moi je
suis artisans vignerons
je pratique l'agriculture la viticulture
du côté de l'avre d'ailleurs ça fait
quatre générations qui ont fait de
l'agriculture la viticulture sur le même
terrain chez moi c'est à dire c'est pas
très original je suis pourtant un bon
suisse je peux vous dire et c'est vrai
que ça n'a pas toujours été comme c'est
aujourd'hui on est le fruit d'un flux
avant cette époque monde à et grand père
quand il est arrivé sur le domaine en
c'est clair on était à l'époque tout
manuel là c'était vraiment les bêtes il
y avait deux vaches il y avait le cheval
enfin j'attends tous travaillé avec la
nature les années 30 son arrivée on a
commencé avec un petit peu
l'industrialisation
après la guerre mécanisation engrais
chimiques
herbicide ça c'était l'époque de mon
grand papa voilà il a vécu cette époque
là quand il a pu remplacer dans le fond
des heures et des heures aklil sol vous
imaginez à lavau n'y avait pas un brin
d'herbe dans les vignes ans était au
travail et la vie y est c'était tout
était pour la vigne quand il a pu
changer ça des soeurs désordre un club
pour juste une petite giclée
d'herbicides il a vraiment pensé qu'il
faisait bon choix même chose
les engrais chimiques sont arrivés après
la deuxième guerre c'était des heures et
des heures de fumier dans les autres
pendant l'hiver des aller retour à pied
quand il a pu changer une hotte de
fumier pour une poignée d'azoté nitrates
ammoniaque
c'était le pied dans les années 70 on
était à fond dans l'industrie autant
l'agriculture était devenu déjà une
industrie ça tournait bien bien mon père
ses rangs s'est rendu compte gentiment
quand même que après toutes ces années
avec clean quelque chose qui allait pas
donc il s'est mis à faire du bio à lavau
les années 70 faire du bio a la bosse
était vraiment précurseur il as b qu'est
ce qu'il a semé du trèfle du shoot chine
l'afssa quelques années et je crois que
la pression sociale était peut-être un
peu force forte et puis une année de
sécheresse
bon mais déjà quand même une prise de
conscience pouvait pas continuer comme
ça moi je suis arrivé dans les années
2000 on a commencé à arrêter tous les
herbicides
on a commencé à cultiver des villas
haute diversité biologique a commencé à
accorder la place à la nature a intégré
la ville dans son environnement
et puis chemin faisant je suis arrivé à
la biodynamie juste agriculture
agriculture c'est bien ça sonne agri
culture on parle bien du culte deschamps
c'est pas un truc industriel avec des
tracteurs et des immenses c'est vraiment
le culte des champs la biodynamie pour
ça aussi ça sonne un petit peu on arrive
à se faire une petite parallèle
biodynamique dynamique de la vie soignez
le vivant par le vivant
par exemple je vous ai parlé des ces
magnifiques pouce de vache qu'on peut
récupérer
c'était carrément luxin on se casse un
peu le dos mais avec ça on fait une
recette qui s'appelle la bouse de corne
par exemple c'est une recette mon
pratiquons biodynamie et qui va servir
dans le fond à améliorer la fertilité
des sols
c'est pas grand chose c'est des petites
doses le mode c'était un petit peu sous
le mode de l'homéopathie n'empêche super
intéressant à faire on dilue un peu de
cette bouse de corne dans de l'eau qu'on
va dynamiser bio dynamique
alors je vous explique pas quand vous
êtes un petit gars comme moi bien au
dessus de la terre général on a les
pieds bien sur terre et qu'on vous dit
ben voilà il va falloir dynamiser cette
préparation pendant une heure vous
n'avez rien d'autre à faire que d'être
là à dynamiser
vous devez simplement faire une heure de
déconnexion complète de votre tête de
toutes vos pensées ca c'est pas mal
parce qu'on passe un peu pour un fou qui
voudraient bras c'est un truc pendant
une heure c'est à dire début c'était un
peu difficile quand même mais il se
passe des choses on brasse aux instances
ont créé des cadeaux on embrasse il ya
un véritable échange qui se répandent en
ce moment là pourquoi est ce que je fais
tout ça par exemple la bouse de corne
c'est l'idée de redonner au message un
message un message de fertilité au sol
est vraiment booster ce côté naturel les
soldes ne sont malheureusement plus
aussi naturellement fertile qu'il
l'était bouse de corne jeu très la bouse
de corne aussi pour l'économie parce que
dans le fond sur un insolent qui est
naturellement sains et fertiles
on s'offre quelques petits garantie pour
l'avenir d'utiliser encore cette terre
et puis la santé je vous ai parlé des
plantes avant alors le pissenlit c'est
une plante qui va dans la préparation du
compost on va pas parler ça aujourd'hui
mais par exemple
lortie lapresle losier des choses que
j'utilise toute l'année quand je vais
traiter mes vignes je rajoute ses
tisanes ou décoction et là on n'est pas
en train de lutter contre quelque chose
en train de renforcer quelque chose
c'est cette idée de biodynamie dynamique
du vivant je traite mes plantes mais il
plante avec d'autres plantes
elles ont une bonne santé tout ça je le
fais pas tout seul mon chien ma compagne
aussi non mais il y aussi les copains
j'ai de la chance on a déjà pu faire des
choses à lavau on est quelques vignerons
à s'être engagée personnellement d'avoir
pris cet engagement personnel d'aller de
l'avant de changer notre manière de
pratiquer notre métier pop à ce qu'ont
d'ailleurs peu fou fou il y en a qui le
disent mais surtout parce qu'on a laissé
cette capacité de voir quels sont les
défis qui sont devant nous et puis de
pas le retour des dos on a déjà pu pas
supprimer les hélicoptères c'est
séromantique l'hélicoptère à lavaur pour
aller faire un tour et déjà c'était
kopter qui entre parenthèses va trier
les vinyles mais déjà plus de produits
de synthèse si j'avais été tout seul il
m'aurait bien écouter en rigolant mais
peut-être pas fait la ferme est ensemble
on y arrive et joyeuse équipe on a tous
pris cet engagement personnel de
s'engager dans vraiment personnel on
peut dire presque au niveau du coeur de
s'engager dans une voie où on pratique
un artisanat on veut plus faire
d'industriel
on veut donner une vraie valeur aux
choses remettre l'être humain au centre
de ce culte deschamps donc vous l'aurez
compris moi je suis un artisan de la
terre et vous desquels artisanat vous
revendiquez vous
[Musique]